now we talk a lot on the show about some
of the big populist issues immigration
trade jobs in the economy the way the
rich have got richer while working
Americans have suffered the way Power
has been concentrated in Washington in
the deep state bureaucracy and also in
our cotton economy with corporations
getting bigger and bigger and real
market competition almost disappearing
in many areas we talk about corruption
the way the elites have grabbed power
and made it serve their interests in the
DC swamp but there is more to populism
than that especially positive populism
if the central message of the populist
revolution is about taking power out of
the hands of the elite and putting it in
the hands of the people at the
grassroots then we need to appreciate
and support the foundations of
grassroots power yes of course that
means individual liberty enshrined in
the Constitution but we're more than
atomized individuals we are members of
society and what are the building blocks
of a strong Society in America faith
family and community that's the focus of
our show tonight now some people might
take these things for granted but we
must never do that because the truth is
our social fabric has become terribly
frayed in recent years recent decades
actually we've seen a massive rise in
family breakdown so many children being
raised in broken homes more often than
not with an absent father communities
seem to be fracturing all around us
local institutions losing their power
and respect and faith well although it's
as strong as ever in some parts of the
country it is viciously under attack
elsewhere in a way that I never thought
I would see in America so how do we
repair our torn social fabric how do we
strengthen those vital components of a
strong society faith family and
community that's part of positive
populism too it's definitely part over
the next revolution we need and it's the
focus of this special show on this
special day I'd love to know what you
think so please follow us at Steve
Hilton X and that next breath
FNC